c'est la frontière la plus spectaculaire
du Caucase mais c'est aussi la plus
imprévisible étant donné l'altitude une
avalanche vient d'entraîner la fermeture
de la principale route du commerce qui
mène en Russie les camions sont
immobilisés sur des kilomètres et des
kilomètres dans les montagnes ces
chauffeurs vont devoir atteindre des
jours pour passer au doigt
mais ils ont l'habitude
sur cet artère névralgique depuis un an
en raison des sanctions de l'Occident
la Géorgie quoi que pro-occidentale est
devenu une plaque tournante pour la
cheminement des marchandises que la
Russie importe désormais des pays du
Caucase et de l'Asie centrale
du Kazakhstan du Tadjikistan de
l'Arménie dit-il avec des produits
locaux comme des fruits des fleurs du
textile et des matériaux de construction
ce chauffeur dit qu'il arrive lui
dérivan avec une semi-remorque remplie
de chips et pas n'importe lesquels
ce sont des Pringles
qui distribue les Pringles est une des
centaines de compagnies qui ont mis fin
à leurs activités en Russie dès le 24
février pour protester contre l'invasion
de l'Ukraine mais les Pringles sont un
des biens sous embargo qu'on retrouve
pourtant facilement à Moscou tout comme
les halfons
[Musique]
pour un distributeur arménien qui les a
importés de l'Europe et les réexportent
à son tour vers Moscou c'est ce qu'on
appelle des importations parallèles en
Russie elles sont devenues monnaie
courante depuis que le Kremlin les a
légalisés pour contrer les sanctions et
les boycottes sans le consentement des
fabricants
la capitale de l'Arménie nous étions
quelques jours avant de venir en Géorgie
et où nous avons pu facilement constater
le mode de soperenzie
il nous a même reçu dans son parc
automobile où son garé des modèles
flambant neufs
des États-Unis et même du Canada en
toute légalité
statistiques d'exportation montée en
flèche vers la Russie depuis tous ces
pays qui maintiennent leurs liens
économique avec elle en Arménie par
exemple elles ont augmenté de 77% de
moitié en Turquie
idem pour le Kazakhstan
bien qu'il soit impossible pour le
moment de déterminer quelle est
l'appareils
en vacances en Arménie
et le transit par la Géorgie quoique
long et dangereux et devenu
indispensable même si celle-ci assure
les pays de l'Ouest qu'elle ne laisse
pas les produits sanctionner entrer en
Russie ces camionneurs nous confient
tout bas qu'il y a dans cette file
interminable des iPhone des ordinateurs
qui vont traverser sans problème
l'ancien sorcelet
importation directe ou parallèle Poutine
peut toujours compter sur des voisins
dociles pour braver la tempête